all right so we have some Orion will of
the wisps action going on noise this
fine gentleman right here hey how's it
going I'm Mark coats I'm an executive
producer with Microsoft Studios and yeah
we're here showing off the latest and
greatest with Orion the world of wisps
so for those who let's say are not as
familiar with the franchise with the
initial one like what can you tell me
that has actually changed in reference
to now the secret yeah so well the basic
concept of the game remains the same in
the sense that it's a we're hoping
people will view it as an excellent
example of the metroidvania genre
awesome so everything that made the
first game great the beautiful stylized
graphics you know the really tight yet
intuitive gameplay and the amazing sound
and the really touching kind of
heartwarming story right that's all back
in the in this and what's a true sequel
to the game so this game takes place
after the events of the first game but
we've also added a lot of new things to
the game let's talk about what you add
it what's the new fun stuff
[ __ ] again a gameplay mechanic wise
well the first thing you'll notice is
that oh my god aurilla he's wielding a
spirit sword you know and so if you
remember in the first game you had sign
and really the only attack ability that
you had was when you were in within
close proximity to another enemy you
could you know do damage to that enemy
well this time around you have we've
created a new combat system okay where
the player can basically pick and choose
different abilities that they want to be
active while they're playing okay and
it's so doing they can kind of customize
the way that they want to play as Ori
just read my mind so pretty much you
giving up a play a little bit more
freedom as far as customization as far
as abilities as far as unique aspects of
things that they can do in game that's
exactly right yeah the game can be quite
challenging I mean that's the part of
this kind of game you know you have to
master the new voice that you learn and
then you get that awesome satisfaction
having done so but um but what we found
is that by giving players more agency to
choose the way that they like to play
the game actually becomes a little bit
more accessible as well so we're really
excited about that and so you know now
or he can wield the spirit sword he can
wield the spirit hammer knives he can
wield the spear
bow and arrow okay so those are some of
the new attack and combat abilities that
we're kind of showing off here and then
you know in addition to that we're also
like he just you just saw he was talking
to one of the NPC characters talk so
some of the characters that people loved
from the first game are back okay
but we're introducing a whole array of
new NPC characters that that you can
discover in the world and when you talk
to them they may send you on side quests
which is also kind of new for the game
that is definitely no yeah just being on
that gold bullying path right so we're
breaking that linear structure so to
speak a little bit more open that's
right yeah just a little bit more open
world to it and you know it's still
there's a main primary path but you know
when you want you can go off on these
side paths and do these optional quests
and maybe find new abilities or new
divide ask you are we gonna be rewarded
for but for trekking off okay that you
decide cuz that's awesome
yeah and you know you'll see a little
bit later here one of the key new
abilities that Ori that we're showcasing
here is called burrow okay and so uh you
know you can see here in the world this
particular level that we're focused on
with the demo is sort of a desert
setting yes with these shifting sands
and these platforms that are made out of
sand that kind of break away or
disappear and so you'll see that
currently different areas are kind of
blocked off like by the sand but once
you get burrow you'll be able to
actually penetrate the sand dig and
burrow through the sand early libero
means you can find new areas and utilize
the brew ability in order to gain access
to places that you couldn't get to
before awesome
one thing about Ori I mean the art style
is just absolutely phenomenal animations
look fantastic just a very very visually
stunning game now what are the other
influences you guys had was far as
during the creation process or just in
general you know that kind of anything
that come even from maybe not even from
video
any other media is anything that kind of
inspired this kind of art style is
really unique thank you so much yeah
we're very very proud of the way the
game looks and we want to bring back
that same trademark stylized you know
sort of presentation that Ori is so well
known for and really take it to the next
level right and so yeah I guess the way
to say it is that Moon Studios is the
development partner that we work with to
create the game and they're really the
creative geniuses behind the game and in
the past I've heard Thomas their
creative director answer this question
by saying that they he was heavily
influenced by a lot of early Disney
movies right see I could see that they
tell a story you know through characters
that really take on human kind of
characteristics that emotional
connection you know it's a very
emotional game I've been kind of feel
away when you get into it with the
characters and of course a lot of the
predecessors in terms of games in the
same genre the metroidvania genre you
know games like Metroid you know games
like Castlevania and these games really
you know set the original foundations
for this style of game and you know our
ambition is to try to replicate that or
bring bring a modern day treatment in
terms of storytelling and graphic
presentations of that genre of game
awesome that was true in the first game
or in the Black Forest and it's true
here with Orion the willow the West
School it looks absolutely fantastic I
think I think Lord Sam he's approving he
hasn't said a word he's just in his
mother's in its own right now right now
this thing looks fantastic and as far as
do we have any idea of a release window
maybe possibly yeah so in our briefing
yesterday we should we showed off and
debut our new trailer which shows a lot
of gameplay both what we're showing here
in the demo but also other yes and we
mentioned at that time also that the
game is going to be coming out in 2019
yes yep so still have times the words to
do but we really want to make it perfect
and beautiful
so we want to take the time that he
deserves as it should you know and we
can't wait man and I'm assuming from
from a technical standpoint you know
we're making some optimizations for the
Xbox one X as far as um true 4k HD you
know any HD offers
yes exactly
nice we wanted to be running at 60
frames a second you'll go for 60 nice a
seamless plug sag that responsiveness
especially with a game like this is well
you know a lot of platform elements and
things like that that we require fast
reaction that's awesome Wow you heard of
your first guy you know similar is that
possibly similar to the Baro ability
that or you might get later yes exactly
right yeah like right now he can't deal
with the worm in only a very specific
way here but you could imagine now maybe
that sand might lead to new areas and so
if he picks up the burrow ability which
is on his way to do that'll open up this
level in an entirely different way nice
man re in the will of the whips man
looks fantastic we cannot wait to see
more Lord Sam is very pleased he's been
waiting all day for this so this is what
exactly where we be lying